la radicalisation de la société
israélienne depuis une vingtaine
d'années ailier manière je dirais très
important en crispation qui commence
avec le retrait de liban qui n'en mène
pas à la paix et il n'y a pas de ya pas
d colonisation au liban et israël donc
le plus un mètre carré les territoires
libanais ce qui n'empêche pas les
risques voilà des jours et la haine et
la guerre contre israël jusqu'à sa
destruction
jusqu'à sa destruction en 2005 israël
s'est retiré unilatéralement de la bande
de gaza il ya plus de il ya plus de 2 de
présence israélienne à gaza et aussi des
quelques colonies de nord de la
cisjordanie
c'est unilatérale très bien ça suffit
pas très bien mais c'est certainement
quelque chose qui va dans le bon sens en
plus c'était c'était avec sharon qui l'a
fait
quelle est la réponse la réponse qu'elle
les palestiniens votent majoritairement
pour les ramasse en janvier 2006 qu'elle
ramasse hamas fait un putsch à gaza en
ils vont tellement loin que c'est
l'autorité palestinienne qui a mis hors
la loi
les ramasse en juin 2007 le hamas était
mis hors la loi par par mahmoud abbas en
2007 on n'oublie pas ça il faut pas
oublier ça et donc gaza est devenue une
base de la base de lancement de
roquettes contre israël donc face à haas
et c'est tant de déceptions la base de
ce qu'on appelait les camps de la paix
en israël s'est écroulé si on rajoute
après tous les autres éléments
sociologiques etc
on arrive en électorat qui est
clairement de droite même si 1
depuis deux ans on a quatre élections la
seule question c'est oui ou non à
netanyahu parce que sinon on a à peu
près 70% à 75% delà de l'électorat
israélien qui pour un gouvernement de
droite
donc oui la dimension religieuse est
important mais je pense pas que il est
déterminant
[Musique]